welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz
today i'm very excited to be joined by
pete
rozinka who is the founder of orc3d
who are a recruitment business that
build help build high performing
sales marketing and engineering teams
for fast growth tech companies
across the us and europe pete started
his recruitment career in 2011
after being in the fitness industry for
several years
and in this time pete progressed from
being a management consultant and a
principal consultant at finney james
for over seven years and before taking
the leap to start his own recruitment
business
orc3d in 2018
and here we are pete for thanks for
joining me on the podcast
and here we are how you doing i'm great
so very quickly i just have to ask
because i forgot to ask this before but
when we say several years in the fitness
industry
yeah so was your actual bodybuilder
no i've never i've never my profession
was a pt
so i used icpt i transitioned into
pt from a kind of typical globo gym
into the the world of crossfit um
which is a love hate thing some people
love it some people hate it
um but i did perform i was i was a
competitive olympic weightlifter still
part of what i do now
but that wasn't my job that was just a
hobby
not bodybuilding yeah exactly exactly
completely different volume okay
yeah the non-vanity version
so where we always like to start on this
podcast is
in your opinion pete what
characteristics and traits do you think
make up a highly successful recruitment
consultant
so look there's loads of kind of there's
loads of tactical skills for me which
we can talk about but i think from a
higher level
the things that we always look for and
if i'm thinking about
high performers it's people who are
truly
goal driven so
what i mean by truly goal driven is
talented people
know what they want to do and they're
not afraid to tell you about it and
to tell you about it with absolute
clarity
i think that's key for me it's not
enough to say i want to be successful
or i want to help people it has to be a
clear goal
so clear goals and and clear being the
operative there is is clarity on those
goals
so i think it's a really interesting one
because
a lack of clarity for me it's kind of
like a manifestation of fear
almost um and what i mean by that is
when a goal becomes really clear there's
a chance that you won't achieve it right
because it's clear so you can you either
miss it or you hit it
so i think people don't get clear on
goals through
fear actually um it's easy to say oh i
want to be
i want to be um a better biller i want
to be a better sales person
um but yeah so clarity truly goal driven
and then thirdly it would be
people who can really take ownership
and really take responsibility which is
that's actually something we
test for and we measure when we're
interviewing um you know
the people who don't play the blame game
and actually take responsibility and
ownership for their own development
their own learning
um whether it's coming to you with ideas
um you know and with that
the thing that underpins everything is
an appetite for learning so if i'm going
to summarize those things it'd be
learning
responsibility clarity and goal driven
and you know so there's a load of
tactical things as well with the job of
recruitment and the different skills you
need for different industries
you know for us we're in a see we're in
a sales industry with
check this out we're selling sales
people to other sales people so
that's a tough gig um so there has to be
a level of
assertiveness with that you know people
who are assertive
um and people who've got natural
curiosity
i think regardless of whether it's
you're curious about
how a watch works or you're curious
about what somebody's thinking which is
kind of more pertinent to recruitment
it's having that natural curiosity to go
lay deeper and to qualify
and not be afraid of um really getting
to the bottom of a problem you know once
you truly understand something
the more you can understand something
the more comfortable you are with
with selling that and positioning that
to your cliente candidate
so that all stems from
a sense of natural curiosity for me yeah
some really interesting things there i'm
going to have to ask
how you measure responsibility but just
quickly because it just as it's on my
mind
i love the curiosity part i think it's i
think that's actually quite
underestimated sort of how
powerful just having that appetite to be
curious is and asking questions or being
willing to ask questions and
i listened to a podcast with i need to
read the book to be fair but it's a very
well read book and recommended jim
collins
good um good to great i don't know if
you've read that
or heard of jim connors but yeah he was
on a podcast and the reason why i'm
sharing that is because
one of his mentors said to him the best
piece of advice he's ever had was
his mentor said to him um the sort of
analogy was at a dinner party you should
be
someone who is not trying to be the most
interesting
but the most interested yeah right
and that i love that and i think that
yeah i saw things
yeah being being willing to be
interested and
being yeah i just think that's such a
great skill to have and
how do you measure responsibility then
how do you do that
because i think that's an interesting
one yeah i mean i don't know how you can
truly measure it
and maybe that's something to work on
something to develop but
and here comes a big name drop but we we
actually use um
we use a guy we use an spq
profiling scoring um okay a scoring
system
which which measures people before they
come in and one of those things that
there's loads of different things that
we measure
and we're a real data driven company but
one of the things that we measure which
in for me indirectly is about
responsibility is a
it's essentially a score which will
assess
how likely is that person appoint a
finger pointer
how likely are they the person to play
the blame game
so the higher score you get on that the
more
of a red flag literally in this case
it's a red score
the more that's a problem so
if we're trying to develop a culture
which is all about a coaching culture
somebody who does take responsibility
for things and somebody's going to
develop
the moment we see high blamers uh
that's a bit of a red flag so that's how
we measure it and that again that's
um i think that's called sbq gold that's
a um
something we've implemented and put in
for pretty much everybody who comes into
the business now
and it gives us a kind of a fair
assessment of
of different people's strengths their
weaknesses
um and ultimately how how well they're
going to do
in sales yeah that's great i think
that's great so
we obviously you've been a recruitment
business owner for the last
two two and a half years so we're
definitely gonna talk about that today
but what i just wanted to find a bit
more about
pete was early days in recruitment so
how would you describe your first year
in recruitment
wow um thirsty in recruitment it's funny
because i was
um as you know through this pandemic and
i promised myself i wouldn't say
pandemic but right throughout the last
year
i'm pretty sure for most businesses
unless you are in healthcare
um maybe in e-commerce it's been about
bd
it's been about bringing on new business
and it's traditionally the thing that
is perceived as the harder job right but
my first
year or years my first four years in
three years in uh recruitment were just
180 bd
so wow yeah i remember you know so i
came in i didn't know any i don't know
any different you know i came in
and i actually came into recruitment to
uh i came into recruitment to earn loads
of money quickly so i could get out of
recruitment
um and and then and then quickly saw
that recruitment was this
you know um life enhancement opportunity
disguised as a career
and learned so many things and i was
like well no i'm
in this now so that's one for another
day but um
i came in and it was just okay do this
pic it was it sounds so cliche pick up
the phone
make these calls to these people and get
through to enough get through to enough
people
and you'll uh find some people that are
hiring
and then you could take some job specs
and that was it that was my job
and i loved it and i didn't at first
nobody loves interrupting people for a
living
um but that became my my bread and
butter you know
what made you what made you what made
what helped you begin
to love it because i think that that and
i'm sure you've seen it now right if you
that's where you started your career
that
that's definitely the area that i found
most difficult uh
sort of early on in my recruitment
career and i think that that shared
quite a lot with people right so i guess
how did you begin to love it
yeah so it was the um
i guess it was two things it was the it
was the the it was the competitive
nature of
not wanting to be beaten you know you
had these people who it was a game
actually
it's just a game you know there's people
on the other end of the phone who i
don't want to speak to you or you have
to convince them that you've got
something compelling
or you have an offering that's
compelling so it's like a game how do i
get these people to
to buy into that well part of it is how
well you can
articulate that and part of it is well
if you can articulate
really well but you only do it five
times a day then you're never gonna win
so like i i'm a massive formulas guy and
it was just right well just do both of
those things really well
then i'll succeed and what really helped
was it was just you know the time was
like right you just need to do but do 80
calls speak to 16 people a day
and just do that and you'll smash it um
obviously it's a little bit more nuanced
than that but
i liked having a plan and having a goal
and just knowing that if i did that
every single day
i'd win so i think that's the insight
though right that you
instead of just going i don't enjoy bd
you broke it down or i'm finding bd
challenging
you broke it down and actually worked
out well actually this is if i
you broke it down to numbers rather than
oh
this is like this is a challenge you get
what i'm in you broke it down to like
right yeah then
basically this is the equation that
should enable me
to achieve what i need to and yes you
just focused on the number like yeah so
i guess
like some of the self dialogue might
have been right so i've just spoken to
that person that now i've only got 15
more left to do maybe i can
get another person off and then you get
what i mean so you create that
yeah so that's really interesting yeah i
mean
for me that it has to be that it has to
be but then i'm
we are so data driven you know and
everything has to have a
metric behind it that's not to say like
we're kpi central but it's like well
it has to be measurable right if it's
not measurable it's not really
a great goal so um that was just dead
clear
it was really clear do that and then
you'll be successful
rather than just what what was
what i'm interested in i really like
asking this question like what if you're
looking back
and i'm sure obviously things change
right but like
what was your most effective way of
hitting
that 16 job spec goal whatever the goal
was but what was your most effective way
of being successful in that role and
getting job briefs and good ones like
what was your most effective way of
achieving that
most effective way i
guess that's hard to define but i think
the the key to it
is consistency you know it was
just like anything training as well you
know it's consistency it's not
kind of going kind of gonna blast out
seven sessions
this week and do three three double
training sessions it's like no you're
much better off if you can just do
four sessions a week every day of your
life so same thing we train it every
with recruitment it's just it's just
reps it's putting in the reps day after
day
and being consistent and
i feel like it's such a high intensity
job it's such a hard job
especially the bd side of it you can
burn out so easily
you can burn out and just be like you're
just getting spanked over the head with
you know these ridiculous numbers to try
and hit or it's like yeah come on let's
go do it
and then it's like high intensity but
then
how long is that you can't do that for
10 hours a day every day some people can
but you're going to burn out eventually
so it's like well if there was some
sensible metric
just doing it consistently so
consistency was
was the key but if that's what you mean
by how i did it and
with it again within like within the bd
aspect of it it wasn't
you know you like anyone you after a
year you've built up a client base
you hopefully can rinse as much of that
client for one of the better phrase
all the jobs within i guess you know
making sure you're getting all the pdf
one client rather than it's not okay one
new job
one new client and then hit and run um
so that was how i found my success by
getting the most out of a particular
client which actually led to me then
working on a load of weird and wonderful
roles that we've never really touched
before in
weird and wonderful locations and then
started up the
european division the international
division and started placing people in
different countries which was
like some second nature to us now but at
the time it was like
going and placing people in germany or
france it's like wow
what we do what are we doing my first
job spec
which it just happened upon i was called
a number on the database with somebody
in german it was somebody in germany and
it was like well
we've got this job on in germany can we
do it all right yeah well we'll have a
go
didn't feel it but it was like what's
this guy doing i didn't know what i was
doing i had no idea
i i definitely wanna i definitely get on
to that because i think a lot of people
are interested in
the sort of the nuances of recruiting in
other markets right that you have to
adapt to or what's different about it
but
just to sort of wrap this up together
then like if i'm listening to this i'm
early on in my recruitment career and
that may mean that sort of i spend
my first sort of 12 18 months first two
years part of that
during covert right and obviously yeah
the bd element is an important part
right
so like what would your advice be to me
then because i'm sure you've had to give
something to buy some of your team like
what would your advice be to me if i'm
struggling at the moment with the
business development side like what
would you say to me that
hopefully would help me get more out of
my efforts or just help me push on do
you think
yeah well the first thing i would say is
um whenever you speak to
before come on to that whenever you
speak to any
any leader who's been through a
recession and
um you talk you talk to them about well
how did you get through the recession
you see this sort of fondness in their
eyes
uh oh god yeah about recession of 2008
or whatever it was
um and so if you've if you started your
career in
in this recession this hellhole
of a market like that's the best thing
that can happen to you
because if you can get through that you
can get through anything you know how
easy it is going to be
um and so my advice would be don't you
know don't gloat too much about how
great
that time was when it really is
it's probably the best training you can
get um
in working through and surviving uh such
a
horrible market um so yeah what
my advice be for somebody who's in that
now is is just that it's consistencies
just
keep going through it you you just trust
the numbers
we always just put faith in the numbers
of you do this
enough times and you'll be successful
where what is
really just self-destruction mode is a
bad market
no one's speaking the phone anyway i'm
just going to make less calls because no
one's going to
you know respond i think that's going to
give me a job
yeah exactly so just keep
keep up with the metrics you know trust
the metrics trust the numbers
know your metrics first but trust the
numbers that's it yeah
um i think that that's the advice isn't
it because early on you might not know
what the equation is you should have at
least an idea of that
yeah and i think that's that will vary
from person to person but it's funny
isn't it
it's not since i started in 2011
the metrics really haven't changed much
um
you know it really it really hasn't you
know was i i'd
get five job specs a week by speaking to
16 people a day by making 80 calls a day
fast forward 10 years later it's really
no different
so it's going to be different for every
market but um
and of course through the pandemic yeah
you speak to
just speak 16 people go you're not going
to get a job spec but
um well we didn't anyway it was like
people were just laughing us off the
phone um i remember one of one of the
lads was like
60 dm's in 60 decision maker calls in
and
and then that was the first time he got
respect throughout that period so it
took
60 conversations yeah but he got there
you know he got there
um and that was just it was just
focusing on the process focusing on the
metrics not thinking too much and
crapping yourself about it's another
week without a job spec what we're going
to do
we'll just look at your numbers i think
i think there's an interesting
thing right there about what you're also
trying to sort of put a bit of a
spotlight on which typically
people don't is like you're
you're basically putting on the pedestal
the process over the outcome
yeah absolutely you should do yeah yeah
but it's it's like but that's what i
mean i think that massively helps early
on as well
if i think back like some it's very easy
to think
that bd session or sort of that whole
focus period on business development and
didn't go well because i didn't get a
job spec
but actually what you're saying there is
if you know your numbers and you know
the process
it's trust the process and and if you
know you've done that and it's like
right i'll look at that in a positive
way do you know what i mean and that
definitely helps with motivation so i
think
that's just that's i mean there's loads
of things in life for that isn't it it's
like about sort of understanding don't
just celebrate the outcome it's actually
the gold is in the process and
if you get really good at celebrating
the process and enjoying that that will
help
that will help you get to the outcome
yeah exactly
and it's that whole thing of how you how
do you incentivize that right so as a
leader
you know you've got the commission at
the end of the day of
you know the placement that comes
through but how do you how do you reward
and incentivize the behaviors that
you're looking for well if you
know if you as the leader trust the
process um
and you can well ideally you can get
them to come up with the incentive
so if you can if you can set incentives
based around the process rather than
based around outcomes then you probably
get the process
results that you're looking for and yeah
again like ideally
everyone's different but we just say
well what do you want for that you know
within reason don't ask for a
let them come up with the the uh the
outcomes that need
the incentives that they want and and
yeah those whatever they want whether
it's time off more money
you know just come up with something get
creative the most creative way you can
do that is
getting them to come up with the people
yeah yeah exactly i have to ask you this
you've been to you say you love
you love the numbers talking about
making sure that yeah
you need to know your numbers i i
remember getting this question through
my inbox and i think it's such an
interesting question but basically
we want to know in your opinion what do
you think is the most
important action kpi metric that
contributes to recruiter success
most important kpi that maps to a
recruiter's success
the contribution yeah that would be um
meaningful conversations so
and the number of meaningful
conversations
yeah well what customers that's
customers so it's
clients and candidates well it's clients
on canvas it's a bit of a cop-out right
isn't it but uh it's neat
i think the key there is it's knowing
and understanding and really
um being true to yourself and what's a
meaningful conversation
yeah that's the reason when that
question yeah so did you get something
out of the call if it's
and if you're just having conversations
for the sake of having conversations
we'll see
how that goes you know yeah you can
speak to 50 people a day but if you're
just talking about the weather
or you're not actually getting anything
out of it then it's no good so
yeah it's it's the number of quality
conversations where you're getting more
information you had when you started
that was that was always the manchester
it was the mantra that my then
boss now investor in auckland said that
was mark neal and it said
just win every call you know win every
call get something out of every single
conversation
even if that's okay well if you're not
working with me right now
and you haven't got anything now will
will you give me a chance in the future
will you work with me
um whether it's getting a lead whether
it's just getting some
some little nugget of information that
you call them again in three months time
you've got something more valuable so
yeah that was always the thing for me
yeah if i think back when i think back
to the metrics right when i started and
even now
the thing that i'm most interested in is
that it's those
decision-making connects it's you know i
would that was always what drove me it's
like right get 16 get 16 every day
so that's the fact that i'm still
thinking about that now i think
inherently means that's the
that's for me the most important metric
yeah so on this i'll
we'll go into pete the business owner
right but
just something just come up for me i
think that's interesting i think peop
recruiters will definitely agree listen
to this that that
that makes sense right meaningful
conversations and these things right and
yeah like you said you spent a lot of
time thinking about you even thinking
about it now
so what i wanted to ask you was i'm sure
you've worked with your guys on this and
this is something you refined you're
talking a bit about
there just win the call but like in your
opinion then like what why don't i ask
you this way
in your opinion where do you think
recruiters typically go wrong
on those connect calls or on those
decision maker connect calls
and because i was thinking about what do
you think makes that dm connect course
successful but you said any sort of
nugget but like where do you think
recruits typically go wrong
and i think especially when you're under
pressure
and where i see it go wrong most is
where you're looking for that short term
win you're looking for that quick win
so i think recruits get a bad rep
because it's all about them
it's all about them it's about give me
what i want
give give me the information even if
even if that's really well qualified
information it's give me
give me stuff give me a job um
what what do i need to find for you
rather than making it
conversely i know we're talking about
the process not the outcome but rather
than making those conversations outcome
focused for the client
so you know even when it comes to taking
their jobs back it's like well
what are the outcomes that this person
needs to deliver not
and focusing more on that which is
helping your customer more so if you can
get them to realize that you're
hopefully genuinely um interested in
their best outcomes and the outcomes
that they want
rather than what you want um which might
not be
take a job spec with them today and
which might not be
get an interview with them right now so
i think the thing is it's difficult
because we're all in we're in this
and we're in perm right so it's
different from contract which is very
very fast moving but
um yeah it's that
it's having that balance of we want
short-term wins and
a lot of people um i don't want to
blanket everyone with the same
idea but you know millennials especially
can be quite short-term focused
um when you're on that call getting
those short-term and give me something
immediately
um that's where i see people making the
biggest mistake rather than thinking
about the longest
longer game and um gathering information
which might help them you don't want to
go too far that way
and it's like if there's an opportunity
to stay in this event yeah yeah exactly
um but for new people coming in it's
like it's the pressure i've
got this got this target on my head uh
or soon to have
i need to get stuff i'm just gonna go
and see what can you give me
um that's the biggest mistake i i see
yeah go on sorry i was just gonna say
the other thing and
it's it's a general one but it is that
is mindset and
um it's coming in knowing you know
most people get into recruitment are
quite competitive and
inevitably you come in and you've got
these other people around you who are
doing really well
and um maybe setting expectations that
you sh of getting too much and achieving
too much
early on um and having that mindset
of it's gonna be hard and you're gonna
get a lot of failure at the start so
you know managing your mindset what what
i was just gonna ask was
if i think if i'm listening to this like
i think that's really a good point
really really great point i guess what i
might be thinking now if i'm listening
to this and hearing you say that is like
well if i don't take a job spec or if
i'm not talking to them about
getting them a person that can sort of
help their business
like what value can i give them or like
what can i give them to get what i'm in
that might be something that i'm
thinking about i mean i've definitely
got some ideas around that but
i sort of wanted to see like if i'm
essentially the rkp i get that but
like if i'm not talking to him about a
job or whatever like what what can i
actually give them
what would you say to that i'd say ask
them
ask them the most of the answers that we
get are from our clients
and are from our candidates so just
asking them you know whether whether
it's learning about the information on
the market
whether it's learning about an industry
you learn most of your stuff from your
clients and
and your candidates so who better to ask
for
if you're if you're saying what can what
can i get out of this or how can i help
them
we're just asking them that okay well if
i can't given that this is what i do
given i speak to these candidates all
day long i speak to these clients all
day long
you're not looking now how can i help
how else can i value to you
um it's a really simple question but
because that involves you doing
something or giving something back
rather than taking it's a
bit of a mindset shift um so yeah
ask them and if you ask that question
every single day you're going to get
loads of value and you're going to
realize your true value you're going to
realize your
true value beyond just giving them
candidates so
but you'll never know if you don't ask
i'm glad you said that
because that's what obviously that's
what i had in my head
this is about you right but i think
that's that's sometimes what recruiters
forget right
i think it's that understanding what a
great like if you're listening to this
this is really practical and really
tactical but what a great question
to try and get in in all of your
conversations
what one thing could i do for you today
that would really help or like like what
a great
question to ask like put on them and say
what could i do that would really help
right and then that's and then all of a
sudden when you find
out that five people go actually p if
you could tell me
if if you could find out or know
what people are typically paying this
type of skill set that would be really
useful for me
and guess what you're going to be
equipped with information that you
typically
may know that could be really valuable
for your next new relationship right
that's exciting i think that's yeah it's
such a great thing to remember
it well it really is and again what's
the blocker to
those to people saying that like this
comes i think it comes with age and it
comes to the experience but
the main blocker again to asking that
question is fear
because especially at the start you're
you feel like you need to have all the
answers
you need to know you need to know you
need to telling them what they want you
need to be selling to them more you need
you need to have all the answers well
you definitely don't have all the
answers nobody does so
the thing that stops you asking that
question the most is fear that they're
going to be thinking or you feel the
need to have the answers already of
knowing how you can help them
because you might have had the yeah you
might have had the odd idiot on the
phone before going well you tell me how
you can help me you're
you're the one um but
you're not and the higher the food chain
you go you ask that question to people
higher up you'll probably get better
answers as well
yeah i think the key thing to remember
here which i which i wish i
really sort of really honed in and
remembered when i was in recruitment
was like and this is what we're talking
about really is like
don't underestimate and forget how many
let's just say customers right so let's
just say c-level people
right so directors or whatever right so
let's just say
as a recruiter don't forget how many
different types of directors you speak
to compared to how they
how many they would in a week so a
director for a particular firm
in a tech firm might only he might have
one or two friends
that are also directors or also in a
similar position to him
unless he's really gone out of his way
to be part of a networking group or
whatever
there's a good chance that he may not
speak to people that are going through
similar challenges and problems as him
well guess what how many people are you
speaking to like that on a weekly basis
as a recruiter
well look if you're hitting your metrics
and you're you're having those
meaningful conversations guess what
you're having 10x
of those conversations and that that's
that's the value that's the insight
um and yeah so i think that's if you
really remember that and you actually
pull if you then put that on to someone
and go hey how can i help you and then i
go
with this well actually that's really
good point actually i speak to about
five different people like you on a
weekly basis i'll let you know if i find
that out and that's
just remembering that isn't it and i
think that's yeah really to highlight
yeah exactly and and you raise my point
depending on how niche you are
most people are pretty niche so they're
speaking to the same people with the
same problems now chances are if you
speak to
six i don't know let's say six ctos in
in the finance industry or something and
you get their biggest problem
well that seventh one is probably having
the same problem and
the eighth ninth hundredth so you
probably
got a lot of information already if you
just piece together those conversations
you've already had
so you'll be quite knowledgeable and
that you can frame that as as to
being you can frame yourself as a real
expert if you just use that knowledge
that you're getting but you won't get it
if you don't ask
the question so you don't have to ask
that every single time you ask it you
say seven times and you've probably got
really good craft yeah yeah yeah so
what gave you the confidence to start
your own recruitment business then pete
a lot of people don't take that first
step so what what what gave me the
courage
um i think i felt like you know i
certainly didn't know it all but from a
tactical point of view from a recruiting
point of view
in perm i felt it was ready for me i was
ready to take that leap
um i guess even
my role prior i've been used to working
solo i've been used to albeit on a much
smaller scale setting up with the pt
business
um so i i'd like
i thought it's funny actually i used to
when i started recruitment i
um i was working with i was living with
um
a guy who was a uh he was a solicitor
but he you know about three years in he
said do you think you could do this by
yourself i was like well
probably but i don't quite feel ready
yet
and it's like well what's stopping you
and i was like well it was just it was
just fear
that was stopping me i knew that um
seven years in
i felt i'd learned all i could really
learn and
if i wanted to go and develop myself
further
and advance myself further that was the
only step for me that
i could really do um it wouldn't have
made sense to go and move to another
fern it wouldn't make sense to go and
become a director somewhere else
it was just if i was going to do it may
as well do it properly
and start something up and yeah it was
scary that was it was bloody scary and
there's a lot of
financial risk um and you have to back
yourself in those first
three four months to bring in revenue
and keep the lights on and that's all
you can really do in those first few
months
um but yeah cliche the best thing ever
best thing ever did
what was the plan what was the plan did
you have a plan what was the plan
i had no plan i had no plan i couldn't
you know i couldn't do anything with my
existing clients
i could go and start from scratch and
hustle but
again because i had been grounded in
that and that's how i started out and it
was just
go and find clients go and find clients
on day one as in
in 2011. it was like that again it was
like okay
up for the challenge here we go and uh
yeah never looked back and then shortly
after that
and started hiring people so as soon as
i knew i had enough revenue to
to keep the lights how long did it take
how long did it take you to do your
first deal
um my first deal was a retainer so
about a week um that's like the first
the first deal yeah
and then the first funnily enough like
the weird thing had you saw retainers
before
yeah yeah so i knew that was it was just
like logical in that that's the quickest
way to
actually get literally money in to keep
the lights on
um but my first deal weirdly enough um
was it's ironic given that now we are
we're a business that helped fast-grow
tech businesses i.e the smaller
businesses
what bigger organization out there is
than salesforce
right so my first deal my first deal
that was actually a candidate place was
at salesforce
um which is which is crazy to think of
it there was a back door in there in
that there was a there was a subsidiary
who got acquired by salesforce
right i knew that i knew the guy there
and
i knew the recruiter there and um so
yeah that was my that was my first win
in sweden
of all places um and actually
that came the candidate that i placed
there came from a video response this is
before before even
this only two years ago it was before
video really kicked off
like in a big way and um yeah i'd what's
up this candidate
i'd like rang him he hadn't responded so
i sent him a video what's up with his
name on the background
okay fine we'll have a conversation and
then fast forward
in the year he started so that was cool
i'll never forget that i should probably
get it framed
[Laughter]
really cheesy in fact one of the guys
that's just started with us and said can
i get my first deal frames
no one's ever asked
a lot of people i feel like would have
wouldn't have had the sort of
guts to make their first client
pay some of the the fee up front like
where
why did you have that those why was you
able to do that why did you believe
do you know what i mean i'm just
interested in that yeah through
necessity
through necessity i needed to i needed
to make this a success i needed to keep
the lights on and
i needed to get revenue in quickly we're
in a market where
you're from taking a job spec to closing
a deal
takes what can you depend on where you
are if you're in europe bloody hell can
take five months
um with notice periods but it takes a
long time um
it's quite lumpy you know quite high-end
sales it's quite
you know long big old values but takes a
while
so how did i do
again i was asked the question you don't
ask you don't get and um
yeah they they completely understood and
they knew that because i was just really
open with them you know you could go in
there and start
pretending that you've got this fully
fledged organization with like
10 people behind you but people see
right through that
and so they they got it but they also
knew that because
if they got their favorite if i retained
them if they retained me
um that they would get my undivided
attention and that's what they got and
that's why we were able to
to work so well together so i just think
again
retainers another really interesting
point i'll name drop again louise archer
who
helped us a lot recently i think she'd
been on with your podcast actually
yeah she was one of them well i worked
quite early on on the personal right
with a personal brand of stuff because
yeah yeah yeah anything online which i
just thought was ludicrous
because she yeah well she was great she
came in recently
and she was helping us with um selling
retainers but again like
selling retainers it's just mindset it's
this thing of when you've been so used
to working contingently
you're not work almost not worthy of it
but how when somebody said how do you
sell retainers
well it's just ask for them i know
there's
all this great training and it's all it
really is good training but it's like
well
just ask and you you just never you
never know
if you ask 10 people you probably get a
retainer
yeah it's that it's every time
this has been spoken about it's that it
is it's the answer
um so what
so you had to get money so did you not
did you sort of not
do it in the like did you not give
yourself any sort of runway like did you
have like three months where
you knew that if like you was okay if
you didn't make any money like do you
not have a bit of a runway when you
started
have you have they run our battery now i
know somebody called me
and it connected to my uh if you connect
it
if you connect it back to your airpods
because i think it's disconnected
no worse
what's that
say again how's that yeah that's fine
yeah we're on
cool okay yeah i can edit that that's
fine
so um what doesn't say did you not give
yourself
a sort of financial runway did you have
one
so shortly after i um decided i was
going to set up
um i was approached by
um the guy i used to work with mark
nealon
and um
when he found out that i was going to
set up um
and i had this this wonderful plan which
was you know
if i can if i can just get to 10 people
if i can get 10 people in two years and
that'll be me
that'll be great and you said before 10x
now he's big gran cardone fun um that
you know he would say well can you get
10 i think you get to 100.
i'll help you get there and so he
came in and put some financial backing
down which enabled us to go and
i say us um me at the time
going higher more aggressively than i
perhaps would have done
had i had i not had that and if it was
just me
thinking okay well i can just make
enough money for myself and if i can
match my
previous salary and yada yada so um
he was really helpful in that runway and
it just became a case of
we'll pay him back you know that was
that was almost
more for me obviously worked with him
previously
for me that was more important he's like
okay well if i can
get him back what he's given um
and then start growing this thing
and that will mean more to me than just
you know getting some deals in and
having an okay life so so yeah
besides that i'm just interested because
a lot a lot of
recruiters will end up starting a
recruitment business on their own like
you did right
so just quickly on that obviously
obviously he had a vested interest right
but obviously part of that is then
helping advice he's trodden on the path
that are going on
it's like what would you say were the
sort of one or two things that
sort of massively helped you early on
that you probably wouldn't have
got obviously if it was just by yourself
right it's a lot i don't know was there
sort of one or two things that really
jumped out that sort of he had a real
big impact on
of interest yeah mindset and confidence
so building comfort building confidence
now i wouldn't say i'm not a confident
person but when you are
either going to start your business
that's a big leap in itself
so then you imagine you're there on your
own
this brand new company that you you've
got this great idea for
and then somebody comes along and goes
yeah we'll make it 100
company you're like you laugh at them
um and that's you know doing that on
your own is
impossible it's not impossible but i
have a few more gray hairs i reckon if i
was doing that on my own
both from a point of view of him being
there to
help support it and to mentor me and
coach me
um but also i couldn't do that alone
without adam you know so shortly
afterwards adam came on board
right hand man and again in all
transparency
for anyone starting up the the thing
then for me was like okay well
i'm about to basically give away nearly
half my company
and you have to have a real level head
on you to
actually see the long-term benefits of
that and
of course now complete no-brainer i
wouldn't have it any other way
you know you have to you have to do this
with somebody else
for so many reasons but there's just so
much to do you know only
only recently we were just redividing
and re-giving up what we're responsible
for
those business leaders you can't
i just don't i think eventually people
do that if they're going to go and run
the race and build a really successful
company
but you can't do it all by yourself so
it was a really it was really wise and
and it was
uh it was a wise move to do it early on
rather than get to where we are now
fourteen fifteen people you know about
it
maybe one difficult well more bitter but
also
it's just more difficult to then start
um
giving people more responsibilities it
just it's hot you may as well if you're
going to do that anyway you may as well
do that at the start
um yeah you're going to divide and
conquer you may as well
do that near the start in my opinion
what
what's happened so far since you
becoming a sort of recruitment business
owner that you've
that you least expected apart from the
grey hairs
yeah i don't know if you can i don't
know if you can see them but there's a
pc
so what what's happened that have been
most what's happening
since you've started this business that
you've yeah at least that you least
expected
well i didn't expect it to be a whole
international
lockdown with us by the buy that would
have happened anyway
um but again i'm really grateful for
that now
because as cliche as that sounds you
that strengthened us as a business so
much more and
because we're so agile um just in the
fact that you know
we were two-year-old business at the
time um we could pivot
really quickly we could make quick
decisions we could um
you know we could just do everything
quicker where these
absolute juggernauts are the businesses
that are maybe 100 people at that point
really feel for them and i'm sure you
know the
successful businesses have got through
that but it would have been a lot more
difficult
um had we not been so although it's
harsh getting hit with something like
that so early on in your career
that's been the making of us um so i
wouldn't expect
didn't expect that i was just going to
say it describe your business
like before covered here and then let's
just talk as we sort of come to the end
here like to just talk a bit about
some of the learnings challenges that
you've like you just said it sort of
made your business so we'll talk about
that but
just describe your business as you went
into kobe like how many people did you
have
what did you do turnover wise first year
and then i think that would be a good
context for people
yeah so first year well um our first
year was like
was a part year but this first year was
like nine months so the first nine
months was like 3 20.
and sec second full the full year
followed was 742
and then this year just gone was 9 10.
yeah
and what uh how many people how many of
you were there when you sort of went
into
like as we were like finding out covered
was a thing so sort of march last year
where was yours
yeah yeah so we were we were about 15
people then
um we're at 14 now that's you know
there's been some churn
um and what
what we were like as a business to what
we were now i would say we were much
more lazy fair very kind of
we we just did okay we just did okay
because the market was so good
what i realized was that we definitely
weren't reaching our full potential we
were just
meeting the we were we were coasting
we were just coasting so what what
covered was great for
was shaping up and tightening our sales
process
to the end degree both from a standards
point of view but also from a process
point of view
um so yeah getting our sales process
refined
and we had a lot of help on that i could
just name drop loads of people but
um you know we had that we had a lot of
help we invested in um we invested
in developing people whether that was
through
scott ransom on some video work whether
that was you with you with you know
with launching our podcast whether that
was um trevor pinder on some sales
training
um you know we had louis archer come and
help with some training so um we had a
lot of help and a lot of development of
people
but then we also invested in our systems
you know we invested in our we got a new
crm
we made sure we had really good metric
tracking software
put in um and so you know
we doubled down on investing in the
people and investing in our processes
um and so now we're a much tighter
business on on
on sales on sales process really
that's really interesting then how have
you
how have you got how have you approached
the sort of how have you approached
keeping your people
not just in terms of like financial and
stuff like that but i'm sure
that must have been like some sure some
of your team might find it difficult in
these things because i think that's what
a lot of people are
interested in i hear about if men you
are talking about sort of me working for
your company i'm going to ha
yeah pete so how did you do with covid
like what went on
like so like how how was you thinking
from a leader point of view
because that's when you're really like
wow okay i'm response for these people
like it's
so how did you approach that how was you
thinking about that
so well by investing in them and giving
them all the training that we could to
make sure they were successful because
the last thing you want to do
is somebody be failing and then it's on
you
and the reason it's on you is because
you haven't you haven't trained them
properly
so it's like right let's just take that
out of the equation let's
make sure that you've got all the
training you need all the tools you need
now it's on you it's not it's not like
okay over to you yeah yeah i know you
mean but you was like
you've done your absolute utmost
platform that they can grow on rather
than
yeah exactly so that was that was the
first part
um from an actual from a tactical point
of view
and and where and how they worked it was
you know the option of
people if people want to work from home
they could if people wanted to come into
the office
you know in between that weird phase of
absolute lockdown and then
if you felt you could go into if you
felt you needed to go into the office
then do
um so it was like okay you can work from
home if you feel you can
you're working with the office if you if
you feel you want to um
so giving that element of flex there
and just uh trying to
um i guess just trying to
support people who were as we are now or
working from home and keeping really
tight on regular comms
um so yeah i don't know if that answers
your question on how we can no that does
i think yeah because we were a lot of
people interested in like
growth getting new people and all these
things but i think what's a really
interesting
point and topic is like what what do you
do what have you got in place to keep
your people your best people from
leaving right and you're talking about
actually investing there in your people
learning and development in fact
investing in the tools making sure that
they sort of got the best tools they can
and these things right yeah yeah
so the other thing as well is the is the
it's having really well with the other
thing we tightened up on as well our
sales process was
you know we had a career development
plan and that was fine but we tightened
up and doubled down on that and just
you know we've now got people coming
into the business as brand new people
who
have the opportunity within a year to
become a leader so
giving people a way to progress those
who are truly
who truly want it it's like giving them
a pathway to get there
um so making that really clear again the
clarity on that was
was really important for us and so um
i guess that's kind of a way of you know
the way of keeping them it's like
who is it you said i think it was
russell clements so the the
recruitment is really simple um find
great people and find a way to keep them
that's it yeah it's definitely it's
definitely not as easy as that
but what was gonna say
a lot of people were interested in this
so i guess like you spoke a bit about
this at the beginning but sort of going
through that whole journey then
like the type of people that you now
want to grow your company with
like has that changed what you sort of
has it changed what you're now looking
look for themselves so you spent you've
spoken about responsibility and these
types of things but i guess
a lot of people interested in us it's
just the most ironic thing ever right
you're a recruitment business you help
fast-growing tech firms find people and
and you find it difficult to find people
for your own business
right so couple issues yeah so like
what so obviously a lot of people it's
like yeah hard working all these things
but like putting all just
this sort of cliche things aside like
what and it seems like you're
about the date and all these things
about what is it that you're
actually interested in looking for when
now hiring for your business and then
hopefully achieving your dreams of
scaling this to a
1500 plus person company what is it
you're actually looking for
people who've got an appetite for
learning people who are truly goal
driven
and can articulate those goals with
absolute clarity
that's it i mean again there's loads of
nuances behind that but
that's it you know truly goal driven
people who are people who are goal
driven again we measure for that but if
you ain't goal driven you don't really
know what you want
that's not to say that you need to know
exactly where you're going to be in 10
years time
yeah yeah we need to have some goals
otherwise it's dead boring it's just a
really boring life without guys
just on this i think that's really
interesting i love how clear that is to
you
i was having a conversation with a um
recruit the other day who who's
who's high performing recruiter has
built really well earned good money
and we're just talking how he's actually
lacks motivation because
he's achieved a lot of his goals
he's a lot this is like this is quite
material but like he's got the car that
he wants he's got this
blah blah blah right just i'd love to
hear your thoughts like if you've got
someone in your team that
they're just smashing it and they're
doing really well and there might be
people listening here
they sort of they've achieved their
goals like how do you then read like
that spark or like how do you then
become motivated if you
sort of feel like you've not achieved
everything but you get what i mean
you've achieved most of things that
you've
set out to how do you then i don't know
i think that's interesting
yeah it is it's well it's like
if you've got all those strings that
you've got all those ex extrinsic
words out motivators ticked off got the
car got the house
everything
a lot of people don't really focus on
their goals and set goals and
um look beyond those materialistic
things and
perhaps it's if you're in that situation
it's sitting down and really just
reassessing what you want out of life
you know what
what drives you what are your goals
beyond
the car and the house and you know you
can get all that for
being a really good recruiter and if
that's all if that's all you're driven
by
but then you're still looking for
something you're still looking for
something
what you're looking for is you know it's
not out there
it's a bit deep but it's you know look
you know you look at yourself a little
bit more and probably think well
actually what do i want out of life
because i've got the car
and whatever else it's just difficult
it's difficult to do that but i feel
like especially during covid that would
have shunned a light on those things
right i feel like
it would it would i don't know if you've
had these conversations but
like it definitely would have sort of
just put things into perspective and
really challenged why you're doing what
you're doing and i think that's sort of
why and
your purpose and what you're driven by
in recruitment is so important to it
you need you need to be curious about
that at least if
if if you're on the path to you've got
goals that do excite you if that's
buying your first property in these
things that's great but like i've had a
lot of these conversations where when
you do get those things then it's like
okay what next
what the hell i've got all these things
around me and i'm still
i don't still feel fulfilled i still
need something to be motivated by i'm
not feeling motivated how do
how do i feel like this so it's i love
what you're talking about it's yes the
intrinsic
it's asking the hard questions why do i
do what i do in these things and
i think it's important to talk about
those things yeah it is
it is i think the and the other the
difficulty is
that recruitment as a business as a
as an industry is obviously very money
driven money motivated and so
come with that it's easy to just attach
goals and motivators which are
materialistic and again the thing that
the thing that's persuaded me to stay in
recruitment
actually was that it was a learning
opportunity and a life development
opportunity disguised as a career
and it wasn't just a way to make great
money but it would just learn so much
so um yeah it's different for everybody
but you definitely i don't think you can
get
you can't get the happiness out of the
job just by making more money you can
for a certain amount of time but there
has to be something else
whether it's helping people developing
people
mentoring people um there has to be
something
before asking these last five questions
then
do you think the best recruiters you've
worked with or the best recruiters you
have in your business the high
performing recruiters do you
do you truly believe that their main
driver and motivation is money
in my business or in general just what
you think what do you believe you've met
a lot of recruiters and
yeah i think i think undoubtedly uh some
of the best recruiters out there
are very money motivated people i don't
think it's the only thing
i think the the thing that separates the
really good recruiters
from the very best recruiters who are
going to go and do something
um are the ones that have a real
interest
in developing others in some way in
whatever way that manifests
but true leadership is having a genuine
interest in developing other people
yeah i just find that interesting
yeah five questions
yeah i'm all about that that's who
that's who i am so so five questions
i've got for you
we'll finish this so first one yeah if
you could
change the industry what would you
improve
um
in some way and i don't know how but i
would the barriers to entry
for recruitment are so low which it's a
catch-22 because that's such a good
thing
and many many great successful
recruitment companies wouldn't exist
had it not been for that however with
that comes the bad
and the reputation and um the industry
as a whole
just gets bastardized um if i could
change one thing
i'd i'd have some sort of standardized
way of entry and make that barrier to
entry a little bit higher
um yeah that's it it's quite vague isn't
it i don't know how you do that
i don't know how you do that yeah
there's a business idea there for sure
because it's definitely the most it's
the most it's the
it's the most common it's the most yeah
it is a lot of people say that
but like you said there's pros and cons
right so question second question
so this can be a podcast an audio book
a book but like what what book have you
read that has had the biggest impact on
you
um definitely uh the power of now
by eckhart tolle i've listened to that
about six times and
yeah yeah i definitely can listen to his
voice
yeah check it check it out everybody so
that i mean you can summarize that in
one
one sentence but yeah i keep having to
go back and re-remind myself of it and
that's to
you know some people live in the past a
lot some people live in the future a lot
mentally i think that's me i i never
worry about the past but i always think
about what could happen in the future
both good and bad
um and that book is just a real good
grounder to just be thinking
you know there's one thing he says it's
like all that matters
is literally what's happening right now
not in 15 minutes not in 20 minutes not
in
tomorrow what's happening right now
unless the bullets come into your head
in the next five seconds what are you
actually worried about
because 99 of the things we worry about
never end up happening
yeah and it sounds it sounds really
simple but like when you
really and we're not really like just
you really get that in your body and
like you really sort of take embrace
that and it's like
nothing matters besides this exact
moment right now it it's freeing
it's completely completely yeah love
that so next question
so if you could write a linkedin post
that could be seen by every single
recruitment consultant
across the world they'd read it what
would you want it to say
um
i wanted to say um
ask why
i love that that's why
yeah right so that would be it it's like
again
most most of the problems that you've
got in life
and in the job i truly believe are
because of lack of clarity
and it's the fear of not fear of not
wanting to
fear wanting to be seen as already
having all the answers or just taking
what you give them
but going that layer deeper asking why
so
truly understanding any problem you've
got ask why
next question yeah what did you spend
your first biggest commission paycheck
on
uh i'm laughing because i can remember
what it was and it was um
it was a set of new alloy wheels for my
audi a3 oh wow
yeah nice yeah
and then and then the second one was on
a new bathroom
there you go chalk and cheese eh
um right last and final question what is
the ultimate goal for your recruitment
career
um to help truly
help vasco tech businesses reach their
full potential
love that pete it's been an absolute
pleasure
thank you thank you so much it's been
brilliant really enjoyed it and you've
helped me hit my water goal for the day
as well